el narco mexicano se volvió a tomar las
calles de Sinaloa 19 cortes de vía
coches calcinados y disparos
contraviones de la fuerza aérea e
incluso contra uno de pasajeros de
Aeroméxico una ola de terror el jueves
después de la detención de uno de los
hijos del narcotraficante Joaquín El
Chapo Guzmán después de controlar la
agresión directa en contra de las
fuerzas de seguridad se identificó a
Ovidio n entre los integrantes de este
grupo delincuencial logrando su
aseguramiento en posesión de armamento
exclusivo del ejército y fuerza aérea
mexicanos por favor pase por favor
También conocido como El ratón Ovidio
junto con dos hermanos forma la sección
de los chapitos o los menores dentro del
Cartel De Sinaloa se hizo famoso en 2019
la guardia nacional le detuvo pero tras
la respuesta del narco en las calles de
Sinaloa El presidente Andrés Manuel
López Obrador ordenó liberarle
finalmente este jueves fue convencida
siendo trasladado a Ciudad de México
para lograrlo se detuvo la vida en
Sinaloa sigue trabajando las autoridades
de los tres órdenes de gobierno para
controlar la situación se sigue
invitando a la ciudadanía para que no
esté en la calle la detención se produce
días antes de la visita del presidente
Joe biden a México Estados Unidos Busca
su extradición por cargos de
narcotráfico lo que representa un giro
en la estrategia inicial de López
Obrador de abrazos no balazos